nobody wants a bird that barks if you're
a bird let me bark Adam he's gonna leave
you alone who's Scottish hear anybody
Scottish around these parts
I'm Jeff Goldblum
oh and I've been given a bunch of
Scottish tweets to try and work out what
they mean
wish me luck okay bye
in my work gave me a piece of chunky and
expect an extra good in it was an
airwaves man you'd need to be a serial
killer to enjoy chewing this it blows
the [ __ ] head off yeah it feels like
someone sat and squirted that too but
Colgate in my gun but not my nose yeah
airwaves to mentholated too strong
although me you know I'm very tolerant
and like in fact a lot of mental
stimulation in my airwaves but we
sisters are having to get eyedrops put
on our ia cuz she got hit by a tennis
ball and she's screaming it stings and
it smells like mint my mom's just stuck
menthol liquid for her vape she's
screamin after the eyedrops ah III but
the mom put some menthol liquid from her
vape too liquidy that that's bad I would
say be careful you know everybody likes
a prank but something medical special in
the eyes that's very risky ask the bird
in Krispy Kremes four five Nutella
doughnuts and she says of your God and a
not allergies hey pal I'm plannin
suicide by donut I've put that's done
some cravings and and strong temptation
I know what you're talking about
there's smoke my age havin Wiens I think
that's having babies and I've just had a
tumble Pringles for my dinner don't beat
yourself up over heaven those
Pringles I didn't have wins until you
know I'm a an elderly gentleman now and
I have a three year old did I tell you
already I read it as my glasses off
because I'm a little bit nearsighted so
this is fine I'm good
naked eyeball there and to see you my
Grenda was reading that gala day program
and it said free rides for all ages and
he said to my gran I'm getting [ __ ]
right down there I'd say to you
Jambo grandad can do it with Grandma
imagine getting our husband no who's
said her to the whole shebang the gaffes
got a spare the man cave
am i doing right by this house my
Scottish my bad Scottish accent by the
way my house has spare room and he
starts Colin at the man cave well all
relationships are unique I think don't
know what this guy's up to in his man
cave or what he intends or there's any
intimacy issue but theoretically nothing
wrong with your own space thanks lad
Bible and the people of Scotland
it's been great understanding your
tweets I so goodbye to you
[Music]